those things with your wife everything
good on that uh marriage oh yeah
everything's great man she's here and
tormenting me with her her britishness
and
and um
everything's wonderful she's my best
friend absolute best friend and arch
rival and the person i love to be around
the most and the person i hate to leave
a room and the person that i argue with
late into the night when i read about
your love story and by the way your wife
was working at the time for paul
mccartney when you met her she was she
was in charge of his whole charitable uh
organization for a year you became
friends and started talking on the phone
right like it wasn't even a physical
relationship for a year
it was just you talk about a slow burn
it was it was hot when it was it was
like i didn't fathom it for that year it
was high-minded and it was
you know it was
kind of like i don't want to say
boringly but
innocuously really a lot of it was about
activism and charity but then one day
something just changed i'll never forget
where i was standing it was like i
hadn't seen her for six or seven months
and i had ended my relationship and my
bus was in vermont in the rain opening
for ray lamontagne in some field
and she had come to boston to visit her
dad and she got she walked up on my tour
bus
and i saw her
at the front door and i i was like
that's it everything's different
there's no day will ever be the same as
this yeah i was just
switched and it was i don't get that
totally infatuated with her absolutely
in love with her and you're telling me
the seven months you were talking to her
it never occurred to you that this woman
was a attractive b that she could you
know there was no fantasizing about her
it's really complicated
was she fantasizing about you like she
probably had the hearts for you and just
didn't open up because why else would
people be talking to each other for
seven months when you think about it she
might was she hot for you
she told me she thought i lacked
substance
right and
um
that you know she just didn't think i
was a viable
or a real person
and she was right at the time
and i think i don't know maybe what
happened was i became one or something
or i was ready to become one but
you know i had spent
like most of my
queer life
dating this is gonna this is maybe an
overshare i forget sometimes that this
is not um a private conversation but
i've spent i spent a lot of my life
really only being attracted to kind of
like masculine women right and so it
didn't occur to me like she was sort of
outside of my gender profile from what i
understood to be my
you know persuasion but then one day i
just saw her and i saw her
and i knew that
you know
that nothing was ever going to be the
same again and it hasn't been